you could see Pete like giggling and
like loving the fact that we're in this
place where you know it's it's like a
death zone
the Rings franchise had more reported
injuries than you could possibly imagine
from glass penetrating through
prosthetic feet nearly drowning in
freezing cold water and dangerous fight
sequences with impaired Vision we're
impressed all of these performers made
it out in one piece everyone got hurt on
this movie everyone was scarred everyone
went through you know a little bit of
physical kind of pain number one no
rehearsal necessary johnris Davis has a
unique fighting style on the set of The
Lord of the Rings most importantly he
didn't really like to rehearse when
shooting Fellowship of the Ring his
method would be to say to the stunt guys
how many of you are coming towards me no
matter how many it was he would just be
like
okay you get me and I'll hit you with my
ax and then you come and I'll hit you
the stunt guys would always go along
with his plan because these were huge
tough guys wearing a ton of armor and
they say okay John you know you know try
try and misses but if you do hit us it's
not a problem yeah John never missed he
would hit every single one there were
definitely a lot of aches and pains
after doing a scene with John brilliant
because it's real you know stunt guy
absolutely terrified number two
definitely not the most chill stunt to
perform over and over Thomas kiwi
actually left the production of the
Rings of power because he didn't think
the stunts were being prepared for
enough apparently the stunt didn't have
proper wiring set up and he wasn't
walked through it beforehand so he ended
up badly injuring his rotator cuff in
his shoulder it wasn't until a day later
that he even got checked out for it
number three let's talk about hobbit
feet
standing up at five in the morning
and and the whole time we're begging to
sit down they weren't allowed to sit
down when their feet were getting glued
on because the way that their ankles
would
they had to stand for the entire
application process with their ankles in
an unnatural position the days that we
don't have feet were really excited
number four Elijah Wood has an
incredible work ethic there was times
when we had time off Elijah pretty much
had no time off ever with that
incredible work ethic comes lack of
sleep but that didn't stop him I've seen
him fall down three sets of staircases
not even that could stop him and then
just get up and go
just woke up number five though Jon was
causing a lot of pain during his fight
scenes he was actually struggling too
it's pretty incredible how well his
fight scenes were considering he
couldn't really see anything John was
wearing a prosthetic that limited his
vision to this to make matters worse he
was allergic to the prosthetic skin he
was wearing and it made his eyes swell
up it was slightly sharp and he he had
no kind of you know sideway Vision it
also made his entire face super itchy
can you imagine at times you just wanted
to rip the damn stuff up and just
scratch
it made him develop topical eczema all
over his face I lost all skin in
it was like a skin peel then after a few
hours it would swell up and turn pink it
was itchy and painful and one felt very
very self-conscious number six
luck was definitely on his side that day
we had a stunt guy lined up to do this
sequence but Vigo wanted to do it
himself Vigo had to float down some
River Rapids in The Two Towers they had
safety guys do it beforehand to
calculate where he would float but it
wasn't exactly an accurate science well
they couldn't calculate and was the
weight of all the stuff there's just
things that changed the way it was for
me he didn't end up floating to the same
spot the guy before him did
spot where the current it's
a straight down
and before I knew it I was on the bottom
the current was so powerful it was
keeping him underwater nobody on set
could find him luckily he managed to
kick the wall and Propel himself out of
the current but it was a really scary
day on set number seven
apparently not your average Splinter
amazingly
Splinter I think probably made of
titanium when they were rehearsing for
the scene and Fellowship of the Ring
where they run to the Brandywine bridge
and jump onto the ferry Dominic Monahan
got a wooden Splinter deep into his foot
you think somebody cut his leg off if
the sweat was poor enough every time
he'd put pressure on his foot he was an
excruciating pain everyone thought this
was really something serious and they
did get this tiny Splinter Dominic ended
up keeping the Splinter he still has it
to this day
number eight Vigo gets a lot of injuries
on set his character naturally gets in a
lot of Sword fights with those sword
fights came a lot of Nicks to his hands
all his hands the the knuckles all had
chunks out of it because he was such a
committed actor he never flinched when
having to do another take no matter how
well you planned it you were always
getting Nicks and little abrasions that
were very painful number nine not really
ideal weather for a swim when Andy
Circus was supposed to shoot his scene
in The Two Towers where Gollum thrashes
around in the water the river was
actually frozen over so they brought a
crew of electricians to melt the snow
the snow was melted away but it didn't
necessarily make the water any warmer
when Andy first jumped into the water he
felt like he'd been punched in the chest
my heart felt like it just stopped
working I was instantly all the
extremities just froze up number 10.
nothing a bit of glue can't fix when
Vigo Mortensen was filming a sword fight
scene he got his tooth knocked into by
the end of the sword and his front tooth
just snapped in half and there's a big
chunk of tooth just broke off and fell
on the floor Migo didn't even care he
just picked it back up and said let's
keep it moving he said get some super
glue somebody get me some super glue I
can just stick it back on and carry on
shooting however they ended up rushing
him off for emergency dental work
instead
number 11 talk about bad luck in this
incident we have Sean Aston in
Fellowship of the Ring running through
the water in his prosthetic hobbit feet
unfortunately just a few steps in and
he's got a huge Shard of glass piercing
through the prosthetic and into his foot
the cut was so deep he had to miss the
rest of the day of filming to get 20
stitches number 12. a rough day at the
office for Orlando Bloom it was painful
it was very painful when filming The Two
Towers he was on his horse and ended up
getting thrown off with one of the
rib I was the first one to score an
injury and I think there was a little
bit of jealousy Orlando suffered through
it went and got it checked out and was
back on set the next morning now that's
stamina number 13. that really really
had to hurt can you try to kick the
helmet as close as possible to the lens
because it'll look great if it just like
flies past us Vigo Mortensen was given
four takes to get it right for this
scene in The Two Towers each take he
kind of got closer and closer to the
camera the fourth take I thought was
really good Peter Jackson thought one
more take and they'd have it he didn't
say anything to us but we found out that
Figo had actually broken two toes the
take was so good they ended up leaving
it in the movie
number 14. luckily no one was actually
injured but it could have been fatal
you're in the middle of fighting and
stuff and you look down and sure enough
there's the fins of a bomb sticking out
on the ground yep you heard that right
they were filming on some pretty
Dangerous Grounds this is a bomb this is
a rocket this is a all these things you
might find out here don't touch them to
make matters worse they were filming a
battle sequence so they were constantly
churning up the Earth with every move
the Army would come intermittently to
clear away the explosives but there were
always some still buried in the ground
number 15 the amount of stunt work in
rings of power is actually pretty insane
lead stunt performer Dana Grant was
admitted to hospital after a head injury
on set she's an award-winning veteran
stunt performer who feels most calm when
she's lit on fire I feel quite at ease
when I do it after treatment at the
hospital it was revealed that she ended
up suffering a concussion as well as
having to get surgery months after the
show wrapped Alyssa Cadwell a
professional stunt performer actor and
Dancer she even doubled for Nicole
Kidman and Aquaman was also badly
injured on the set of rings of power the
scene involved her falling into a large
water tank but unfortunately her head
struck a bolt in the process she was
unable to come back to work for months
luckily she's okay but it was definitely
a traumatic experience
broken toes chipped teeth painful
allergies avoiding landmines and several
hospital visits later we've got the
entire Lord of the Rings franchise and
TV show to binge what do you think was
the most painful scene to film